se trata de un desafío mayor el
transporte y la conservación de los
millones de vacunas que serán usadas en
la campaña de inoculación en francia
tienen movilizado a toda la cadena de
frío de la industria farmacéutica
nacional y es que en este país las dosis
más usadas necesitan permanecer al menos
170 o menos 80 grados celsius toda una
novedad en el mundo de la vacunas ya ha
dicho en ahora normalmente las vacunas
se conservan entre 2 y 8 grados celsius
y sobre todo no deben ser congeladas se
genera csa durán en cambio algunas
vacunas contra el cob it se conservan a
temperaturas bajo cero y no hay que
descongelar las hasta su uso acá la
fragilización en el hospital de nantes
al oeste de parís los farmacéuticos de
la institución están a cargo de las
condiciones en que se guardan las dosis
desde que salen del congelador hasta que
se inyectan a los pacientes
y las vacunas no salen del refrigerador
hasta que tenemos a la persona frente a
nosotros lo que garantiza el buen uso de
cada dosis de acción pero los
especialistas de refrigeración en
francia consideran que lo que a ellos
les concierne la campaña de vacunación
tiene el éxito asegurado
el gran volumen de vacunas no es un
problema para nosotros estamos
logísticamente preparados tenemos que
tener confianza en la cadena logística y
la cadena de frío
lo cierto es que por ahora el volumen de
vacunas a conservar no ha representado
un desafío para francia con algunas
centenas de dosis aplicadas el país está
en retraso con respecto a sus vecinos
europeos